le groupe l'est républicain et la parole
est un monsieur marcel bonnot de chez le
président mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le garde
des sceaux ministre de la justice
monsieur le ministre
un décret du 26 février dernier vient
révéler la liste des tribunaux de
commerce spécialisé issu de la loi
macron au risque de pêcher paris
modestie qu'il me soit permis de
rappeler que ma collègue cécile
intermédiaires et moi même avons mène
une mission 2013 sur l'évolution de
notre justice commerciale et de nos
conclusions nous préconisions
effectivement l'avènement de
juridictions commerciales spécialisées
pour les procédures collectives les plus
complexes
des études ont été faites les tribunaux
de commerce s'y sont attelés il est un
postulat qui était incontournable
c'est la mise en concordance de ces
tribunaux de commerce spécialisé avec
des bassins d'emploi le 27 novembre
dernier votre prédécesseur lors du
congrès national des tribunaux de
commerce donné la liste des tribunaux de
commerce spécialisé besançon venait en
tête par l'ordre alphabétique ce n'est
pas un hasard s'ils ont bien considérer
que le nord franche comté le premier
bassin industriel de france psa alstom
general electric les microtechniques à
besançon et bien d'autres le 22 février
vous avez reçu le conseiller national
des tribunaux de commerce
aucune observation n'a été faite sur
cette liste quatre jours après besançon
disparaissez haut niveau au profit de
dijon il ne s'agit pas d'opposer des
territoires au sein d'une même espace
régional
mais cette radiation de besançon créé
l'émoi
d'autant que la presse révélait que
s'être changement de décor en quelque
sorte d'élu procédait d'une démarche
d'une personnalité politique dégénère
dijonnaise proche du chef de l'état
alors monsieur le ministre les arguments
avancés de dernière heure sont
contrariés par la réalité procède d'un
prisme déformant hier président de la
commission des lois nous avons salué
votre sens de l'intérêt général et de
l'analyse
je vous demande solennellement sans
passion de bien vouloir et aussi
l'apport mais aussi mais celle d'hélène
négociations la parole monsieur le garde
des sceaux me
de la justice monsieur jean jacques
urvoas oui monsieur le président
monsieur le député marcel bonnaud c'est
vrai c'est vrai ce que vous dites c'est
toujours difficile de faire un choix je
les dis à catherine vautrin la semaine
dernière entre deux villes dans le cas
d'espèce écarté l'argument politique
nous sommes là nous nous sommes là dans
deux communes qui sauf erreur de ma part
on des députés ont des maires
socialistes oui ou non
besançon dijon donc c'est pas un
problème politique
c'est un problème de choix je vais vous
dire monsieur le député pourquoi nous
avons choisi vous avez très justement
rappelé que christiane taubira le 27
novembre est venu dans un congrès elle a
fait un message vidéo que j'ai regardé
tout à l'heure elle ne donne pas la
liste la liste a été donnée par la suite
et la liste a été précisé en disant
voilà ce qui est soumis à discussion ce
n'était pas une liste de décisions je
vais vous dire pourquoi l'arrêté que
j'ai signé comporte dijon je les dis
pour catherine vautrin et je le dis pour
dijon ce sont des critères que j'assume
en cas d'espèce le nombre de magistrats
en capacité de faire face aux procédures
collectives et plus important à dijon il
y en a 28 qu'à besançon 19 le bassin
économique de dijon est plus important
puisque les entreprises implantées dans
son ressort
89 société comporte plus de 250 salariés
vous savez que c'est le critère 250
salariés
il y en a 80 9 à dijon 59 à besançon
l'expérience du tribunal de dijon est
très forte puisqu'elle a eu à connaître
des procédures collectives de grande
entreprise vous le savez très bien vous
êtes député du département sur le groupe
belvédère qui a 4000 salariés sur les
sociétés cleia sur les sociétés qu'eole
sur les sociétés de teletech eric
alauzet est aussi intervenue sur ce
sujet il a écrit au président de la
république je le dis a comme à tous les
parlementaires parce que vous avez été
très nombreux à m'écrire en me disant
pourquoi mon tribunal et pas le tribunal
d'un côté parce qu'il faut faire des
choix j'assume les choix que j'ai fait
dans l'arrêté je suis désolé monsieur le
député merci monsieur minuit la parole
est à m